uh it it was a a big issue it was a big
deal and now there's some blowback and
albert breer who coincidentally or not
interviewed nick casario last week now
the texans gm previously the patriots vp
of player personnel reportedly
belichick ignored his scouts in taking
and kiel harry with the first round pick
in 2019 the receiver from arizona state
there was relationship there between
belichick and the head coach and and
harry came in and had a great visit you
don't work out when you visit the team
but had a great visit with the team so
belichick ignored the fact that aj brown
and debo samuel had higher ratings by
the scouts who had put in the work and
it
had had done the grinding and the effort
and the analysis and the vetting
and look at what harry's done and look
at what samuel and brown have done and
that i i feel like
that's cassario's way of saying don't
blame me to the extent that robert kraft
is trying to throw this on me that the
difference this year is i'm gone no
maybe the difference this year is
belichick's listening to the scouts a
little bit more because two years ago he
didn't well
all right here the first thing i'll say
is i would be shocked if it was nick
casario i really would caserio
somebody's talking i know somebody's
saying i'll get there you're right i
think somebody is there's no doubt
somebody's saying it you know but nick
casario is such a he's like belichick in
a lot of he's a machine i mean it's one
of those guys he's not necessarily mr
social
charismatic guy that way that's not what
he is he's not going to charm your pants
off or do anything like that where
you're just like man this guy's smooth i
love listening to him talk what a great
conversation no that's not what it's
going to be it's very wait here's the
facts of the matter i'm going to talk
about football he's a real football guy
he wants nothing to do with media albert
breer is pretty connected up there in
new england he knows he knows a few
people and here's like another he
interviewed caserio last week he was a
very chummy conversation my point is
this if it's not casario breer did him a
disservice by not saying my source isn't
casario because anybody who's paying
attention is going to look at this and
say it's casario who's a little bit
pissed off sorry london and all the
cities in the uk because
you can read between the lines as i did
saying this is less about belichick and
more about casario i i get it i mean the
vault has been open about criticizing
belichick on all this stuff here you
know over the last year so everybody's
looking to you know take this angle to a
degree and you're right i mean you're
right albert breer probably could have
done a solid and said something like
that it's not cacerio but here's the
other thing too and this is why like hey
bill's done a great job up in new
england of you know
they for a long time like not a lot of
people got out of that building but here
in the last few years a lot of people
have got out of that building we got a
few gm's around football we got
ex-coaches who were head coaches here
there all that and you know i and this
wouldn't be the first time bill
belichick hasn't listened to you know
the scouts board and everything like
that and done his own thing i mean
really this is pretty commonplace stuff
with head coaches who have the you know
last say gm word type of thing and yeah
it's gotten belichick in trouble i mean
there's no doubt but i'll say this mike
i was there for two drafts right
and one of the drafts i could still
remember i mean as vivid as ever it's my
first draft as an nfl organization i'm
sitting right outside the draft room
now
the pick is going to be
jamie collins from southern miss right
second round i can remember nick casario
walking out of the room and his head was
shaking and i was like oh somebody
doesn't like the pic that's about to
come up here and pop up on the board and
it was jamie collins and i remember all
the scouts and everything going oh my
gosh why would we take them now and do
all that well he was awesome right from
the get-go so belichick was right also
happened with chandler jones and then
another draft so same thing where it was
just like the scouts were like hey well
we didn't have them rated this high well
he's bill belichick he had him ranked
higher obviously now he's missed and all
that i know that but i don't think this
is that crazy and it goes back to my old
thing mike that i say yeah there's too
much emphasis on the person and the
mental aspect instead of just the pure
ability on the field sometimes up in new
england and i i will always think that's
what gets them in trouble in these
situations
and as i say it's not just the drafting
it's the developing because it's not
like they are reaching for guys who
aren't regarded as draftable by 31 other
teams everyone that they pick is getting
drafted by someone else in the higher
rounds
nikhil harry would have been drafted by
someone else right but at some point the
guy's under your tent and you have to
develop him and that's that to me is the
great chicken and the egg question here
how much of it is mistakes in drafting
how much of it is mistakes in
development and would these guys have
developed the better players somewhere
else because it's not like he's shocking
us with these names no that aren't even
in the binder who is this guy i never
heard of this guy may as well have
drafted turd ferguson
i like it i like it i had to work it in
there yeah you were watching aaron i had
to find a way well that should be
happening
the rest of the day turd ferguson
all right that was last night
but
i will side as far as that question that
you posed there which is a good question
that it's more on the true evaluation
there turd ferguson all right it's it's
more on that it's not on the development
because he's he's obsessed with
development and technique and doing the
right things i've never seen a team more
into doing all of that stuff you know
would i want to just go you know you
know some of these guys and then kill
harry it just
it was questionable about him anyways he
was a very on the fence guy if anybody
can remember back to that year you know
it just was yeah he's big and man when
he gets the ball in his hands he makes
some things happen but i know i was one
who and i'm not alone i'm not trying to
pat myself in the back here where he
wasn't one of my top five receivers
because i was like he he never gets open
he can't get open against anybody and
that's kind of important in the nfl but
they went with the size you know what he
does with his ball in his hand probably
his football iq we met him he seemed
like such a good guy and all that and
because of that yeah they left debo
samuel and aj brown on the board who
have been kicking butt let alone with dk
metcalf as well
yeah and one last point on this yeah
what's that turd if it wasn't casario
thanks if it was
not the first time i've been called that
if it wasn't casario
i i i hope he made a phone call at some
point over the last couple of days since
the story emerged to make sure bill
belichick knows it and accepts it
because
you don't want to be persona non grata
with bill belichick you never know when
you're going to need a job back in new
england again if things don't work out
in in houston the last time i checked
that they're not really working out so
far in houston uh
so uh and look i
i i and and i know that there are people
in the meteor like oh you're not
supposed to guess on whose sources well
it's that obvious and when it's that big
of a deal how are you supposed to do
look the other way oh i have no idea who
he may have spoken to he just
interviewed the guy last week
so uh and and he was the obvious if it's
not belichick it's him who's the target
of the comments made by by robert kraft
especially since he's not there now
craft says oh we're doing a different
approaches here yeah we don't have nick
casario anymore he didn't say that but
that was potentially implied
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports